Speaker 1: Remember that you can join the
discussion on The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash redit. That's
R.E.D. Dite a few posts I spotted this morning. I
want to bring to your attention because I think
they're interesting. Our user noshed. He asks
what's going on with the Matt Gates investigation?
Has it all been swept under the rug?
Writing I'm horrified that so much has come out
about Gates and yet he's still going about life,
business as usual. I understand high profile cases
take time, but what exactly is the timeline here?
This is exactly why when back in the summer, all
of the news articles were saying investigation,
arrest may be imminent and Gates is a partner in
crime, was confessing and pointing the finger at
Gates. This is why I was saying, I don't know
that Gates gets indicted. I don't know that
Gates gets charged. I don't know that Gates gets
arrested and why there was no particular reason
other than oftentimes these guys just avoid
consequences one way or the other. Now,
we don't know the status of the investigation.
I'm hopeful that it will at some point lead to
charges, if that is what is determined should
happen on the basis of the investigation. But
this is exactly why I said let's take it a step
at a time. I'm wondering just as much as you are,
what is going on with Matt Gates. Another post is
about the reduced price of at home covid testing.
Remember last week Joe Biden announced that the
covid at home covid tests would be offered at
cost. Wal-Mart has lowered the cost to
fourteen dollars for a two pack. And as
User Bay Photo points out, if this is at
cost, it will be too expensive for many.
And I think that that's absolutely right. I've
said before I think that at five dollars a test,
it starts to become I don't know about appealing,
but doable for people who say might be having
people over for an indoor event. And they
say, hey, you know what, let's be extra safe.
Let's test everybody for a test. I do think that
seven dollars a test is probably still too high.
And I don't know how much at home testing
we're going to get voluntarily at that price.
Maybe the prices will continue to come down. But
I think around the four dollar a test mark is
what would make sense to me. So far it
seems like it's not going to go below seven,
at least in the immediate. Another user asked,
does David think teachers are the problem with
the education system in the US writing? Does
anyone else get the impression David puts blame
on teachers and schools for some of the problems
of today's society? I'm sure he doesn't intend to,
but at times it sounds like David is trashing
education and teachers. He will say things
like the U.S. education system is failing or
schools don't teach critical thinking anymore.
While that's true, an uneducated listener might
think David is advocating for privatized education
or incentivized teacher pay, both of which have
been studied extensively and are terrible for
schools, teachers and students. No, I want to be
so that that is not what I am saying when I say we
have a failing educational system. I am talking
about a combination of misplaced priorities
as a result of often politicized school boards
that have been taken over by right wingers who
don't want critical, critical thinking, taught
or philosophy or epistemology, etc.. So so
that's often partizan school boards and it's a
funding issue where we always have money for,
you know, the stuff. Right. You know the drill. We
always have money for bombs. We always have money
for war. But when it's education, we always have
to be fighting for and justifying every dollar.
So I'm not blaming teachers. I think 90 something
percent of teachers are doing the best they can
with the resources they have and the curricula
that they are in many school districts
obligated to teach to and teach from. I am not
blaming teachers. I am not blaming teachers.
Glad for the opportunity to clarify. Join
the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom Reddit.